VAN RIPER: I'm here to
welcome Austin Hill Shaw.
He has his book out, "The
Shoreline of Wonder: On
Being Creative."
It'll be available after
the talk for $10.00.
If you're interested,
see Dave here.
For those of you who
don't know, I'm Van Riper.
I'm the gPause program
manager here at Google.
And one of the really
pleasures of my job
is to be involved in
setting up these events.
But I want to give a call
out to Rachael O'Meara, who's
been a great 20% volunteer
for this program.
Couldn't be here today, but
she does the vast majority
of the work of setting
up these gPause talks,
and couldn't be doing
this without her help.
So I wanted to mention that.
And then I also wanted to say,
people sometimes here at Google
think that gPause
is about group sits.
And I just want to
take this opportunity
at the beginning of this to say
it's really about supporting
Googlers living more mindfully.
And we believe that meditation
practice is one of those ways
to help people to do that.
I think this talk today
is really interesting
because we're talking
about creativity,
and I think our mindfulness
practice, whatever
form it takes, can
really inform that.
I know the logo-- I don't
have it up here with me--
but the gPause logo has
that little video pause
symbol in there.
And it is important
to take those pauses,
and that's what our
program is about.
But we live most of
our life in flow, just
like the video in play.
But it's that time we take
for the pause can really
add to the quality of the flow,
and help with creativity and so
forth.
And I know that Austin is going
to talk a lot more about that.
So it's my pleasure to
introduce Austin Hill Shaw.
[APPLAUSE]
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: Thank you
so much for having me here.
The wonderful thing about
having a talk planned,
especially around things such
as mindfulness, creativity,
and the workplace,
is that is allows
me to create sort of a
cauldron in my own mind
by which I'm trying
to understand
the information
better and better
so that I can present it in a
way that is succinct and has
a framework that's unified.
And there's nothing more
that I love than doing that.
My mind loves to be in this
space of creating frameworks,
and trying to understand
some of the things that,
for me, are some of the most
important aspects of being
human.
And it's really interesting
to have that opportunity
to do that.
And I'm really happy to
be here, because this
is the opportunity,
this is the place where
that starts to get presented.
So this is a place where I get
to be spontaneous, and also,
help, with your help,
in order to understand
the material better.
But before I get
started, first of all,
I want to thank Van for all your
work in helping me get here.
And also Rachael O'Meara.
This talk would
not have happened
without Rachel O'Meara.
We met a couple years ago at
the Wisdom 2.0 conference,
and she was writing a
book called "Pause."
And pauses are incredibly
important in our busy time.
And we'll talk about what
those pauses actually
start to look like.
Anyways, I'm really
indebted to her.
And I'm also indebted,
of course, to Google.
In preparing for this, I
recognized the first time
I ever heard about
something called Google
as an organization, I was
in Cuernevaca, Mexico,
in 2001, working on
a children's library,
where it was a
design build project.
So we were basically mixing
concrete by hand all day,
and pouring columns.
And so almost every evening we
had a tequila tasting, where
we would sort of relax.
And during one of
those tequila tastings,
a person came up
and said, hey, you
got to check out
this search engine.
It's amazing.
It's called Google.
And during the
tequila tasting, I
thought, first of all, what's so
amazing about a search engine?
This is 2001.
And two, what an interesting
name for something,
to have something as the
biggest number is possible.
And here you are, this
massive organization
with all these tentacles
out into the world.
So it's really an
honor to be here,
and it's an honor to be
part of the gPause program.
So today I would like to begin
with a little bit of a sense
of where this all comes from.
And in 2004, I was participating
in a three-month meditation
retreat.
It's called a traditional
rainy season retreat.
And during that retreat,
I was getting a teaching
on what's called
the Wheel of Life.
And the Wheel of
Life is essentially
a teaching about how people
get stuck in habitual patterns.
It's what's called a Hinayana
teaching in Tibetan Buddhism.
But it's basically a map
of how people get stuck,
including hope and fear,
what are called the six
realms, and even what's
called the 12 Nidanas,
in terms of how we habitually
relate to the world.
And during this talk, I had
just graduated from architecture
school a couple years earlier.
And I thought to myself when I
saw this, I thought, you know,
that's not only a map of what
they call samsara, or confused
existence.
It's also a map of how
people get stuck creatively.
And that planted a
seed in my mind in 2004
that has never left.
It's something that I just
mull over all the time.
And the really question
was is, what is creativity?
What is this thing that has such
universal appeal, but is often,
I think, so misunderstood?
So we're going to
start to unpack that,
and we're going to unpack
that within the context
of mindfulness and
creativity, and also how
this applies to the workplace.
So before we go on, I'd like
to start with the end in mind
about where we're actually
going to with this presentation.
And what I mean
by that is that I
want to have the vision
about where we're
going as we start to think
about mindfulness and creativity
together.
And for me, it has
to do with basically
what we call the connecting
of heaven and earth.
The type of Buddhism
that I practice
is called Vajrayana Buddhism,
which is Tibetan Buddhism.
But the idea behind Vajrayana.
Vajra means lightning
bolt. And it really
is that sense is that what
you're doing in the Vajrayana
lineage, and in the
practice, is you're
connecting heaven and earth.
That means you're trying to take
these big, spiritual, religious
ideas, but root them into
everyday ordinary existence,
and not just certain
existences, but everything,
everything that you do,
to weave that awareness.
Another word for
Vajrayana is tantra,
and tantra means thread.
It's a thread of
awareness that you're
weaving through all activities.
So we can see the
similarity right now
between the Vajrayana
and mindfulness,
where we're going with that.
But what I want to
do is really create
a spot, a spot that
represents that place.
And it's experience.
It's really beyond words.
But I want you to invite you all
to step into that spot with me.
I'm going to put it right here.
Right here is where
that spot's going to be.
But before I go there, I want to
recognize, when I come in here,
I have my own hopes and fears.
I have my own ideas on
how this is going to go.
I have my own nervousness
about the experience,
about what may or
may not happen.
And yet at the same
time, what I want to do
is surrender so that I
can be in that flow space
that Van was talking
about earlier.
So I'd like your
help in doing that.
And I want you to go
there with me, OK?
So on the count of three,
I'm going to step out.
Again, here's my partial
reality over here.
And in just a moment,
on the count of three,
I'm going to step
into the space,
into the vajra space where I'm
connecting heaven and earth,
OK?
One, two, three.
So this is the vajra space.
And this space, even though
it has a fancy-sounding name,
it's something that
everybody experiences.
These practices of
mindfulness, meditation,
and even the things that
we do in creativity,
are all geared to getting this
into this space, because when
we're here, there's a meaning to
our life that is beyond words.
It's ineffable.
Then the other thing that
happens in this space
is not that we're passive,
nor are we like hamsters
on a hamster wheel.
We are in a space that
the Taoists would wu wei,
actionless non-doing,
a place where
being human and being
creative and being aware
are happening just naturally.
And I want you to close
your eyes for a moment,
just close your eyes, and
allow yourself to picture
an instant in your
life where you've
been in this place,
where you have
that sense of profound,
enlivening connectedness
with everything.
And not only that,
you were doing things.
You had this feeling
of making a difference.
And even beyond that,
you had this experience
of feeling alive.
And notice how this experience
is not something exotic,
but it's actually home.
This is home.
It feels so good to
be here because this
is what we are meant to do.
We're meant to be aware
and use our awareness.
We are meant to create and act
upon our innate creativity.
And we were meant to
connect with others.
We're meant to exercise our
humanity in a cooperation
that's built into our DNA.
Even with people that we
don't fully understand,
we have this incredible
ability to cooperate and learn
from other people.
So you can open your eyes again.
So back in the '90s,
the late '80s and '90s,
my first love, in
terms of probably
a mindfulness practice,
was rock climbing.
And for 10 years I threw
myself into that sport.
And the reason that I
loved rock climbing so much
was because it put
me in this flow state
where I was using my physical
body, I was managing my fear
and planning my energy.
And I was connecting
with nature.
I spent lots of
times in Yosemite.
I've climbed all the
formations there,
all the major formations.
And just being on those
1,000-foot spaces,
moving up little crystals
and crack systems,
and feeling this sense
of your smallness,
your tininess in this
immense environment,
was incredibly
enlivening for me.
And it was also a bit of
an addiction, addicted
to the adrenalized
experience, addicted
to those sorts of things.
Addicted to wanting to be
there pushing boundaries.
And I even-- the
person who got me
into climbing, who was my
best friend in college,
died in a climbing
accident in 1996.
So part of what
has led my path so
of wanting to know more about
what it means to be human
was that immense
loss in my life,
of not having that person there
anymore that I loved so much,
and who took me to
these incredible spaces.
And so when I talk
about this first of all.
I want to talk about
this place which
is opposite of creativity,
the opposite of creativity.
What might that be?
Just imagine what that
might be in your mind.
What is the opposite
space of creativity?
Any idea?
Just think about that.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a lot
things at the same time.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW:
Multitasking, doing a lot
of things at the same time.
Great, great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUSTIN HILL SHAW:
Being in a rut, right?
Being in a rut.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Conformity.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: Conformity.
Yeah, exactly.
Conformity is one of those.
So I've thought
about this a lot.
I used to think that the
opposite of creativity
was destruction.
But I realized that's
a paired opposite.
Any time something is created,
something else is destroyed.
If I sit down in front
of a piece of paper
to go write something,
that piece of paper
is transformed from a
blank sheet of paper to now
it's got marking on it, and
my pen is slowly bloodlet.
So destruction is a natural
pairing with creativity.
But the opposite of
creativity, as an experience,
is addiction, addiction.
I got that from
reading a book called
"In the Realm of
the Hungry Ghost:
Close Encounters
with Addiction,"
which I'd highly
recommend to you,
by a guy named Dr. Gabor Mate.
And there's another
book called "Cutting
Through Spiritual
Materialism" by a guy named
Chogyam Trungpa, where he
talked about, in our lives,
we are addicted to
three basic things.
He called them the three
lords of materialism.
We're addicted to
materialistic things.
concepts and world views.
And we're also addicted
to spiritual experiences,
including substance abuse.
It falls into those areas.
And Trungpa said
basically, you don't
have to struggle to be free.
You don't have to
struggle to be free.
Freedom itself is the
absence of struggle.
And when you see
yourself in that space,
in the vajra space,
which is your nature,
there's no struggle.
The world's no longer a series
of obstacles or coincidences,
or this or that.
It's synchronicity.
It's magic.
It's flow.
So that's the opposite
of creativity.
The opposite of
creativity is addiction.
I'm going to walk over
here for a second,
and let's talk a little
bit about mindfulness
and try to identify with the
opposite of mindfulness is.
Any ideas on that?
Ignorance.
Ignorance definitely has
a component of that, yes.
Other ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: What's that?
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: So
having a sense of presence
is a part of the
mindfulness, yeah.
So I agree with that.
OK, good.
AUDIENCE: Obsession.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW:
Obsession, right.
Yeah.
Just this sort of, a
lot of mental activity.
So when I booked this
talk with Rachel and Van,
I booked it right before
I went into the mountains
with my dear friend William.
I'm 45 years old and I've
known this person for 45 years.
And he is the one that
got me into meditation
in the first place.
And I went up there, and on the
first day, we're up at 11,500
place, and a place we've
been going for 11 years,
where we go practice
high in the Sierras.
And I said, William, can
you help me understand
this phenomenon of mindfulness?
Because with all the
hype around it right now,
I really have no idea
what it is anymore.
And so we talked about that.
And we're going to get
into what I think it is.
But I want to give
you an example
of how the opposite
of mindfulness
works itself out in my own life.
So I don't consider
myself to be a good cook.
I grew up in a household
where food was not valued.
And it just was about
getting fuel in us,
but it wasn't a joyful
presentation, by any means.
And so when I find
myself in a kitchen,
I really feel like I
have to concentrate.
I have to do work
in order to keep
all the different things going.
And I found myself, often,
at the cutting board.
And I'll actually start to get
myself into a semi-flow state
every now and then.
And inevitably what
happens is, I think,
gosh, I'm being so mindful
right now, so mindful.
And inevitably I'll almost
cut off one of my digits,
or something like
that, or something
will spill all over the place.
And it's like, oh,
that's not mindfulness.
Whoops.
So the question is,
what is mindfulness?
And really, the relationship
and mindfulness and creativity,
and the way that I understand
it, go totally hand in hand.
And there's different
levels of it,
and those are where
we're going to explore.
The different
types of creativity
and the different
types of mindfulness
really go hand in hand.
And you have to understand,
I started this venture
on what is creativity outside
of a meditation retreat.
So these two are just like
braided together in my mind.
But we're really going to
start to get a sense of what
that looks like.
So let's-- first of all,
before we go into that,
I just want to create something,
which is what I call the ground
of creativity.
And the ground of
creativity is basically
whatever is that
organizing force that
has been here since the
beginning of the universe.
I mean, if you think about
it, the only elements that
were in the beginning
of the universe
were mostly hydrogen,
some helium,
and trace amounts of lithium.
Just three elements, right?
And now some 14 billion
years later, we have this.
I mean, it's incredible.
Like I have the
screen over here,
and somebody's
talking on the mic,
you know, adjusting the sound.
He's not even here, and he's
orchestrating this thing.
I mean, it's crazy what
we've come up with.
And so before we even start
talking about human creativity,
we need to talk about the
creativity of the universe.
And the interesting
thing about it
is, in this phase of creativity,
there's no mindfulness at all.
Mindfulness and awareness
exist as a potentiality.
There's one view
of Buddhist thought
that says that actually the
universe is brought into being
and goes through this
period of self-organizing
so that you can get conscious,
self-aware beings so
that the practice of ripening
and working with karma
can start again
from the imprints
of the previous universe.
And I love that idea, that
you go for-- again, it's
been about 14 billion years.
And now suddenly, in this
little window of time,
we have come to self-aware
beings, at least
in this neck of the woods,
working on our stuff.
We're all working on
our stuff on some level.
So what are the three
principles of what I
call the ground of creativity?
One is what I call dynamism.
Dynamism is basically
that things are always
moving and changing.
Everything is
And within the
spiritual realm, this
is the laws of impermanence.
Nothing lasts forever.
And so that's something
that we have to relate with
in order to
understand our lives,
and organize our
lives around that,
because the changes
in things are
one of the things that actually
promote our creativity.
Now if we go over here, the
next thing that we have,
which is related,
is interdependence.
Things are always changing,
but they're always
changing in relationship
to other things.
Think of the law of
universal gravitation,
that everything out
there in the universe,
all the matter out there
is affecting other matter.
And then you step into
the third component, which
is essentially, sometimes when
I'm talking to organizations,
like business organizations,
I call it diversity.
But my favorite word
for it is, going back
into the center, mystery,
or mysterious complexity.
We really don't know
how the universe began--
even though we have a
theory-- or what's before it.
We really don't know how
life began, although there's
ideas around it.
And we really don't know where
conscious self-awareness is.
These things that we
rely upon every day that
are the groundwork
of our lives, we
are not even totally sure
how they came into being.
So mystery is not a
thing that's a bad thing.
When we're able to
step into that mystery,
we find our lives being
really-- how should I
say-- full of wonder.
When we can drop the need
to know all the time,
we drop into this
space of wonder.
That's why I titled
my book, actually,
after many years of
thinking about it,
"The Shoreline of Wonder:
On Being Creative."
It comes from a quote
from a Methodist minister,
who I wrongly ascribed the book
to a guy named Huston Smith,
who's a religious scholar.
And anyways, this
person said, "The larger
the island of knowledge,
the longer the shoreline
of wonder."
The larger the
island of knowledge,
the longer the
shoreline of wonder.
We know so much, right?
And that knowing
is great, but it
is unbelievably eclipsed
by all the things
that we can't know, we won't
know, we'll never know,
and yet are allowing us
to live out our lives.
So that sense of mystery.
So again, the
ground of creativity
consists of dynamism,
interdependence, and mystery.
Now before we go on
with that, I want
to do one quick
reading from the book,
but I would love to have
my friend Dada do it.
Would you do that?
DADA: Yeah.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW:
Please come on up.
Do we have the microphone here?
This is Dada.
DADA: Good to see you.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW:
This is a person
who's obsessed with
creativity as much as I am.
DADA: We're friends.
I love this book.
And I love the way you
just described that image.
It really got me.
"It's all in there, waiting,
just waiting in the time
before time.
The universe, our universe,
packed unimaginably
tight, indistinguishably
tight, packed
into a single point, a
point infinitely smaller
than a grain of sand, the
rawest of raw materials
awaiting the miraculous
complexity of a single atom,
while the solids,
liquids, and gases
that will come from those
atoms, the stuff of the stars,
planets, and moons, indeed,
entire galaxies and clusters
of galaxies, the cosmic winds,
the lines that will become
the horizons and the edges
of door frames, planes
that will become meadows and
the surfaces of alpine lakes.
And the volumes that will
become oceans and mountains
and bathtubs full of
splishy splashy toddlers.
The light that will erupt
in the east each morning
and flood through
the kitchen window,
the future debates over
what to call Pluto,
the weight of autumn, and
the promise of spring.
Orion's belt, Cassiopeia,
up and down, near and far,
left and right.
The carbon atom,
the water molecule,
semiconductors,
bacteria and viruses,
fish and flowering plants,
the early nervous systems.
Indeed, conscious
self-awareness itself,
the awareness of being
aware packed in there, too,
packed in there with
memory and language
and with all those sparklers
of emotions, love, grief,
and anger, rubbing
shoulders with the asteroids
and their dark matter,
the possibilities of Jesus
and Buddha and Muhammad
and Lao Tzu cohabitating
in dimensionless space.
The cave paintings of
Lascaux, the pyramids of Giza,
the sculptures of Bernini,
the paintings of Kandinsky,
the soulful jazz
improvisations of Miles Davis.
Polio and the vaccine for polio.
Waterfalls spectruming through
the colors of the rainbow,
moonlight on the mountains, and
the unrepeatable configuration
that is you.
All this floating in that
awesome sea of nothingness,
packed, simply packed,
waiting, just waiting
like an unlit match
or a shrine box,
waiting like the
bedrock in a fault zone,
waiting like a
landmine in the jungle,
feeling, in its own
strange way, the feeling
of being so intensely
small, hot, and dense,
having absolutely no way of
knowing what it will become,
and yet becoming
everything with no need
to reconcile repress
anything, simply waiting
for that improbable moment that
nudge, that flick of the wrist,
the magic words
uttered, and boom--"
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: The
universe as we know it began.
Thank you.
So that sense of togetherness,
this timelessness,
this connectedness, that
experience of all the things,
that potentiality that was
there 14 billion years ago
and is now kind of
here right now--
that is the mystery and
the experience of being
in that creative space, of
connecting heaven and earth,
right?
Of sensing the
miraculousness of our lives.
s It's so easy to lose
touch that our lives
are so utterly dependent
on everything all the time.
And the beauty of our lives
is that as human beings--
this is often called
the desire realm,
but it's also called the
enjoyment realm-- we really
get to enjoy experiencing life.
We get to eat food,
taste it, and our bodies
take care of the rest.
And beyond just that,
there's like a three-
to five-pound mass of things
that aren't even our DNA.
They're helping to process us.
This idea that us as individuals
is-- we're really ecosystems.
We're ecosystems that are
here, but they stand outwards
to infinity, really.
And that is the
ground of creativity.
And that's the thing
that we're tapping into,
that sense when we're having
these moments that we're going
to talk about in just a second.
So again, right here we have
the vajra space, remember?
That's the center.
That's the center, OK?
Now I want to step
into over here.
Vajra space here.
I'm over here in a place which I
call the experience of insight,
the experience of insight.
And this is the
aspect of creativity
where we have those aha moments.
Those aha moments where
it's a light bulb going off
on top of our heads.
And it has the experience
of something coming to us.
So as a lover of
creativity and innovation,
one of my favorite
stories about the Bay Area
comes from an insight that
still just blows my mind.
And we have to go back to
Cincinnati, Ohio in 1889
to see where this
actually happened.
There was a gentleman
by the name of Joe
who was 19 years old
at the time and was
a sophomore at the
University of Cincinnati.
And he decided he was going to
go on for football practice.
And he was Jewish in a time
of rampant anti-Semitism,
and he was only a little
bit over five feet tall.
And as the story goes, he
went out onto the field
and was brutalized, brutalized
before practice even began,
brutalized so much that
he ended up in a hospital
on the banks of the Ohio River.
Well, Joe's bed-- he was in and
out of consciousness for two
weeks, as the story goes.
He got throttled.
So as the story
goes, here he is.
He's in his hospital
bed, and he has
a window that's looking
out over the Ohio River.
And spanning that river is
the longest suspension bridge
at the time in the world,
which was known as the John A.
Roebling suspension bridge,
designed by the same guy who
designed the Brooklyn Bridge.
And we don't know what
happened in those two weeks.
But we can imagine, again, him
in and out of consciousness,
that he's probably saying
to himself, you know,
I'm not going to be a
very good football player.
But I might be a
good bridge builder.
Because that young
Joe would go on
to be Joseph Strauss, who was
the chief designer and engineer
of the Golden Gate Bridge.
So this is an
experience of insight.
And the way that I
understood this was actually,
I looked around for,
what is an insight?
What are the defining features?
A guy named William
James wrote a book called
"The Varieties of
Religious Experience,"
specifically the
chapter of mysticism--
he gave it all to me.
He said, basically a
mystical experience,
which is basically a unit
of experience with something
larger than yourself,
has these qualities.
It's ineffable, it
is beyond words.
It comes with a sense
of absolute truth.
They're usually brief.
They can be micro instances,
sometimes several hours,
sometimes a series of days,
but not much longer than that.
And they tend to be passive.
Think of Joe on
his hospital bed.
He's having this
thing coming to him
in his most compromised state.
And the final thing
is, it happens
in the minds of individuals.
Often in mindfulness and
spiritual traditions,
you get the sense
that the individual
needs to let go of
their individuality.
And I agree, we need to be
let go of the ego structures
that bind us and keep us
in addictive states, right?
But it's great when
we actually recognize
that our lens on the world
is unfathomably precious.
Nobody is ever going to see
the world quite the way we do.
And we're changing
all the time, too.
So that experience of our
lens on the world in the here
now is unbelievably precious.
So this is the
experience of insight.
Now in the language
of mindfulness,
this is what you're doing
when you're meditating.
Specifically, when
you're meditating,
when you're doing what's called
Shamatha-VIpassana meditation,
one type, which shamatha
means dwelling in peace,
and vipassana that
means insight.
The idea is that you're watching
a focal object, normally
your breath.
You're watching your
breath go in and out.
Sometimes you're
doing it sensorially.
Sometimes you're riding
your breath experientially.
But you're focusing
on your breath.
Now, how many of you are
meditators in the room?
How often would
you say that, when
you have your focal
object, are you actually
on that focal object?
Let's say, like, maybe you're
there 90%, 95% of the time.
How many people do that
during their meditations?
Good, OK.
How about 50% of
the time that you're
actually watching your breath?
All right.
What about-- let's
go 20% to 30%, maybe.
All right?
Cool.
All right.
What about most of the
session is basically you
watching your mind go vrrrrrr.
So the thing about mindfulness
is that, really, mindfulness--
I mean, we don't want
to beat ourselves up
when we're looking
for this awareness.
Mindfulness is in
this context is just
a realization that we
actually are thinking
and that we need to
go back to the breath.
Does that makes sense?
It's just that awareness that
allows you at some point to go,
hello.
You're actually not
on the focal object.
And so that moment-- even
though sometimes we go,
aarrrgh, what am I doing?
It's really, we should
be celebrating that.
It's like, oh, that's
the mindfulness.
It's allowing me to
return to the breath.
And in returning to
the breath, we're
returning to what we
would call wisdom.
Wisdom, in the
Buddhist tradition,
is defined specifically
as primordial knowing
before thought intervenes.
Primordial knowing before
thought intervenes.
Think of Joseph Strauss
there on the bed.
His executive functions are
probably not working so well.
And yet his primordial knowing?
We're all indebted to that.
I look at the Golden Gate
Bridge and I just want to cry,
it's so beautiful.
The art deco, just the
span, looking at the camber
from the East Bay.
It's unreal.
it's so beautiful.
And it came from that
experience, that aha moment.
So this is
mindfulness, phase one.
And in the Buddhist
tradition, we
would call this the Hinayana.
The focus is on the individual.
It means the narrow
path, the narrow path.
The Hinayana, the narrow path.
And the archetype
in this is what
is called the arhat,
one who tries to exit
samsara and move into nirvana.
They're exiting.
They're wanting to exit
the cyclical existence
of the world.
That's the goal in this
realm here, all right?
So let's step off
there for a minute,
and let's go over here
now, on the opposite side,
on the opposite side.
This is what I
call manifestation.
And manifestation--
manifestation comes from manos,
you know, the word for hand.
And the idea is, we want to
take these ineffable experiences
of insight and make them
something that we actually
can touch, that can be
tangible, that we can feel.
So manifestation, in
this case, basically
consists of just the opposite
of what we had over here, right?
Instead of being ineffable, we
need to be able to define it,
all right?
And then suddenly you
have this paradox here,
which is like, well, then you
have absolute truth over here.
You have to be flexible.
That's the thing, is your
insight in the moment, I think,
is absolutely true.
But time goes on, and it may not
be true five seconds from then.
It's almost like-- if
anybody's done the I Ching,
it gives you a glimpse.
You throw the I Ching,
and it's like, here's
a glimpse of reality
in this moment.
But as you know, from
dynamism and interdependence,
things are always changing.
Always changing.
So again, we have to
define what we're doing,
but we also need to be flexible.
This is the phase where
we also have to be active.
We have to have a sense
of, we're doing things.
And we also-- this is the
sense of where, actually, we're
being active there,
and we're also learning
to work with other people.
This is the phase
where we start to work
in the spirit of the collective.
So those are the things that
we're starting to contact.
We're being active.
We're going out in
the world, we're
working with other people.
That is the experience
of manifesting,
just the opposite of
what we have over there,
just the opposite.
And so one of the things that
I love to think about here
is that another way of
understanding manifestation
is-- do we have any Bassnectar
fans out in the audience?
Anybody ever heard
of Bassnectar?
So Bassnectar is a DJ that
actually was born in San Jose.
And right now he's a
multimillion-dollar act.
He's one of the biggest
touring acts out there
in the electronic
dance music scene.
And Lorin had a moment
of insight, too.
He was, as an 11-year-old
boy-- he's from San Jose,
and it was October of 1989.
And suddenly he finds himself
with his mom in the car.
And suddenly, in October, the
Loma Prieta earthquake hits,
and there he is.
And I was actually 19
years old at the time,
on the Berkeley campus
sitting at Sproul Plaza.
So I know what that's like.
Suddenly around concrete
everything's shaking like this.
But then there's
this distinct feeling
of a water wave moving through,
moving through the landscape.
I'll never forget it.
It was so paradoxical.
This was concrete,
but you could feel
the elasticity of the earth.
So anyways, Lorin is
basically an 11-year-old boy.
And what he would start doing,
based on that experience,
is he would start to
try, in his own way--
either consciously,
subconsciously-- to recreate
the energy of that cataclysm.
Who's been in an
earthquake before?
OK?
If you notice, when
you're in an earthquake,
there's a couple
different things.
There can be fear, right?
We experience that.
But there's also amazement.
You're really
tapping into, again,
one, the dynamism of the earth,
but also the interdependence.
It's like those plates
pushing against each other,
and one's suddenly slipping.
So Lorin started to explore
different things that
had that energy.
First of all, he was into metal,
like really heavy metal music,
which had a lot of energy to it.
But then he discovered
the rave scene,
which is all about love and
community and people dancing.
And simultaneously while
he's growing and having
these influences, Silicon
Valley is growing up,
the technology is coming into
being, all the mixing things,
all the sound, all the
speaker technology.
They can do ultra
high frequencies
and ultra low frequencies.
And now he plays
these concerts that
are just-- they're
immersive experiences where
he's building up
the energy, almost
like the energy in the earth.
And they does a drop, where you
get this unbelievably powerful
rolling bass line that just
moves through you like water.
And for people who
like his music,
it's almost like a
spiritual experience.
People walk out of there being,
like, that was unbelievably
amazing.
But that is, again, the
experience of manifesting.
He had that insight
years and years ago.
And yet now, he's
translated that
into something that offers this
incredibly powerful music that
is both a joy to listen
to, and is also lucrative.
He's made a lot of money.
He's a very generous guy.
He's given a lot of
money back as well.
So that's the experience
of manifestation.
Now if we start to look at
this in terms of mindfulness,
and this is really the essence
of what we call the paramitas.
And the paramitas,
there are six of them.
I'm going to get them
in the right order.
The paramitas are
basically the idea
that when we're
working in the world,
there's six things that
we want to keep track of.
We want to have generosity.
We want to have discipline.
We want to have patience.
We want to have exertion.
And we want to have a
practice of meditation,
whereby we're constantly
refreshing our minds.
Those are the five
relative paramitas,
which are the perfections,
the way in which we work out
in the world.
But then, capping
all that, is what's
called the prajna
paramita, which
is the umbrella of
wisdom, which, again,
like Joseph Strauss brought into
the world, and also Loren has.
It's that driving
force that it makes
you continue to move
forward towards recreating
the experience of insight
that you had initially.
Does that make sense?
So again, those are
the ways in which
you start to work in the world.
This is the world
of manifestation.
And this is the realm, in
terms of Buddhism, which
is the idea of the bodhisattva.
The bodhisattva's
role in the world
is to keep helping people
understand their own confusion
and move towards wisdom,
and they keep coming back.
They say, I'm going to
forgo my own enlightenment
until all people
are enlightened.
That's the realm
of the bodhisattva.
It's a service role.
So when you're manifesting
creatively, think about,
how can I bring
things into the world?
How am I serving
not only the product
or the service that I'm
creating, or the art form,
but how am I serving
moving through things
in my interactions with people?
The bigger the project
you have, the more
you have to collaborate.
So the more lives you
have in order to touch.
This is also the
seeds of innovation.
This is where innovation starts.
In the aha moment,
nothing's happening.
It's all just experience.
But over here, we actually
start to get into the realm
of innovation as well.
So just to show how
this starts to work
in the workplace, this
experience over here,
the number one thing that
we can do, in my opinion,
to promote this sort of
aha moment in the workplace
is just to appreciate people.
I have a five-year-old that
just started kindergarten.
And it's her second
day of kindergarten.
She had trouble going to
sleep the night before.
She woke up late.
And it takes me about 12 minutes
to get to her school in a car,
and seven minutes to
get her there on a bike,
and I love riding my bike.
But it's kind of a cold morning.
I had her on the
back of the bike.
I'm riding her to school.
She's just crying,
I don't want to go,
and I'm like, oh gosh, you
know, what's going on here?
And so we get to the school,
and I'm walking her up,
and she's like no, I don't
want to, I don't want to,
I don't want to.
And I bring her up to
the teacher, and I said,
Sierra's been having really
big emotions right now.
She's pretty tired.
And the kindergarten teacher
just went down to her level
and said, I'm tired, too.
It takes me about a month to get
used to being back in school.
Would you mind if your
daddy brought you over here
and read a book together?
And just like that, she
felt totally at home.
It was like magic.
And my heart exploded.
I'm like, that-- well,
you just got her.
But that's appreciation.
And it doesn't have to
do with doing anything.
There's nothing there.
Just, she's connecting
with her humanity.
And then over here in
the manifestation realm,
if we think about this,
what do you think this?
This is just acknowledgement.
especially if you want to
be creative and innovative
in an organization,
you not only want
to acknowledge what a
person is doing well,
but also her attempts
when things don't go well.
We have to have license
to fail if we're actually
going to be creative.
We have to have that
safety by which we
can start to feel that
we can try things,
and we won't be reprimanded
if it doesn't go well.
So this is just acknowledgment,
acknowledgment both for things
that go right, and also
for efforts that don't.
As Ed Catmull, the president
of Pixar and Disney animation,
he would say, our
failures are always
investments in the future.
And we encourage people to
fail, not late in the game
during production, but early.
You manage for the
failure, because you've
got to have it if
you want innovation.
All right?
So let's come back here.
So now we're going
back to the vajra spot.
And again, this is the
space of creative flow.
And over there, this
is the realm of wisdom,
primordial knowing before
thought intervenes.
This is the realm
of compassion, doing
things in the service
of others, including
the other part of ourselves,
that higher part of ourselves.
Now let's go to the
center part here.
This is what I call
self-expression, self
expression.
It's a word we've
all heard, but I
like to think of it in terms
of the way the Jungians use it,
and the perennial
philosophers used it.
And the self we're talking about
is the big self, the big self,
the big self that's connected
to the vibrant world.
Has anybody ever seen this book?
"Goodnight Moon?"
So to me, this is a great,
great, great example
of understanding the two types
of awareness that are happening
in self-expression.
If I open the book, "In the
great green room there was
a telephone and a red balloon
and a picture of"-- full
color-- "the cow
jumping over the moon."
So this-- we go
to this next page.
This is the realm of self.
This is what they would
call the divine ground.
It's the vibrant sense of
a dynamic, interdependent,
mysterious world.
And yet throughout
the book, the person
keeps focusing in on
things, individual objects.
In order to create,
we need both.
We need to be able to have those
big, great green room moments.
We also need to be able to
focus on specific tasks.
So in Buddhism they
would talk about that
as the two truths, the
absolute truth, which
is the great green room,
and the relative truth,
which is our ability
to understand where
we stop and the world
begins, what we're good at,
what we're not good at, what
our bank accounts are doing,
what things are happening time.
Those two things both need
to be honored in there.
But we're in the middle of this.
When we're in the
vajra spot again,
in this place of
self-expression,
we're doing both
at the same time.
We're maintaining the sort
of awareness that is here,
this big awareness, this
connectedness, this aliveness
that's always there,
while simultaneously we're
making discrete decisions,
taking discrete actions,
following tasks, anticipating
outcomes, working with others,
having one conversation
after the next.
And this is the space
of creative flow.
And this is the place of
aliveness in our lives.
So the question is, how do we
cultivate this in the workplace
and in our lives?
What are the main things
that we need to do here
in order to cultivate that?
And the main thing
here is that we
help people to establish
their mission and vision,
and also to hone their craft.
So the United States
is amazing, because we
have people from all over
the world who come here,
and they leave traditions
from other places, right?
That's the amazing thing.
That's why this is one of the
most creative and innovative
places in the world,
because everybody
leaves their traditions
and comes here.
But the confusion
about being here
is that we don't have an
overarching narrative of what
our lives are about.
And that's actually
really hard on us,
if we don't identify
what it is it
we're actively working
on in the big sphere
of what our lives are about.
So creating a vision,
a sense of where
you're going in your life,
and creating a mission
starts to bring in
this need for meaning.
We all have this intense
need for meaning.
No other creature
quite has that thing.
But yet we are the
ones-- you know,
we have to understand our lives.
So that's the first thing.
And when we start to
create that meaning,
it allows our lives to,
again, have direction.
The distractions
that come up-- we
go, oh, that's a
good distraction,
so I should go in
that direction.
But that has nothing-- or,
here's another thing that's
coming at me, but
that's not going
to get me where I want to go.
And suddenly, all the
choices that we have,
they start to fall away.
And you start to feel called
in your vocation, what
it is you're here to
do, to offer the world.
And everybody is being called
to do something in the world.
You have to define it.
My mission in life is to
empower others as creators.
That's my mission.
And that's how I think and
view the world all the time.
How can I empower people?
I work with a team of designers
and an architectural design
firm.
How can we work
together in order
to create this structure
for this person?
How can we empower
the clients to give us
their deepest
beliefs and values,
and how are we going
to design from that?
I'm constantly, in every
interaction with my kids,
with my wife, how can I
empower them as creators?
How can I be the
person that does that?
So that's, again, establishing
your mission and your vision.
The other thing, I think,
is to hone your craft.
Humans love doing
what they're good at.
There's a guy named
Johnson O'Connor, who
was a guy from General Electric
who had basically recognized
early in the last century
that-- it seems obvious now--
but people are happiest doing
things that they're good at.
And they love building
upon those skills as well.
So in a work situation, we
want to figure out, again,
what is our sweet spot?
What are we good at?
Where does our magic come from?
And focus on that.
And then also look at how we can
intersect with other people who
have opposite talents,
or different things, can
so we can help one another.
That's the joy of collaboration.
That's the joy of
working with one another.
And this space, again,
this is the arhat,
the one that wants to leave
and go into the bigness.
This is the
bodhisattva, one who's
actually working in the world
but maintaining that awareness.
This is what we would call the
tantrica, again, the person
that, in every interaction,
is weaving wakefulness
into every experience
as much as possible.
And the difference between this
space and the other two spaces?
This space and that space still
have a residue of confusion.
Like, I'm a confused person.
I'm confused.
I don't know exactly what to do.
I'm wanting to move out of
my confusion towards wisdom.
When we step into
self-expression
and we own our
creativity, then we're
in the space of basically
being fully human.
We are saying, my basic nature
is wakefulness, not confusion.
My basic nature is wakefulness.
And that's what you feel when
you're in the flow state,
that your basic
nature is to be awake.
And that's what the
mindfulness practice is,
and that's also what
creativity has to offer.
So I know that we went
over a lot of information.
I just want to offer you this
as a way of understanding
all the information
that we talked about.
Again, like I said, I love
making maps of creativity,
spirituality.
"The Shoreline of
Wonder" is a dharma book,
but it's geared toward
the secular audience.
My languaging is
always towards, how
can I intersect the people
that need this the most?
And in my opinion,
it's the ones who
maybe don't want to go
into the mystery, who
want to ignore dynamism
and interdependence, who
want to fixate on
their life, you
want to retire by a
certain time in their life
and kind of cruise.
This is targeting that.
And in the workplace,
all these ideas
here-- again, the ground,
which is in gray, and then
the other ones-- the connection,
the making the difference
and meaning-- those are the
basic needs of being human,
which is accomplished through
appreciation, acknowledgment,
and empowerment, empowering
others as creators.
And here's a little bit
of a close-up of that
just so you can see
it a little better.
And if you would like a
copy of this yourself,
you go to my website and
you can find it there.
If you go to AustinHillShaw.com,
you can find that.
And there's a whole explanation
on the back whereby you'll
get all the information
that we talked about here
just a moment ago.
So I know that we're coming
up really quickly on time.
I don't know if you have
a moment for one or two
questions.
But thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for the talk.
I have a question
about-- so bringing this
into the workplace, where you
mentioned getting to a flow
state, and a relationship
with that between-- how
is that necessarily related
to something that is actually
beneficial in a larger sense?
A company that makes
cluster bombs that
wants to function with less
dysfunction in the workplace,
as one example.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: That's
a fantastic question.
The question, again, is how-- if
we're entering the flow states,
that's great.
But what if our outlook is to
build a better bomb, a more
destructive element?
So, you know, how to say.
I love humanity.
And when I'm working
with individuals,
what I've recognized
through the years is,
people want to
love and be loved.
But hurt people hurt people.
That comes in the prison system.
The meanest person in
the yard is the one that
has been hurt the most, right?
So you're right.
A flow state can be
used destructively.
But the beauty of a flow state,
when it's working actively,
is it brings forth what
I call transmutation.
Transmutation is
basically moving--
it's almost like alchemical,
bringing a base substance
and making it elevated.
But in human beings, it means
taking all those hurts become
bottled up in the
ways we shut away,
turn away from our
natural creativity
into addictive patterns.
We face those
patterns and we step
back in through the
process of transmutation.
So one of the highest
expressions of creativity,
in my opinion, is healing.
And so we can't
make people change.
But we can demonstrate,
through own insights,
our own manifestation, and
our own self-expression,
a different path
of doing things.
You can't force
anybody to do anything.
But you can surround
them with love
and not make them
wrong for that.
At the essence, this
is a path of love.
And there's things that look
like self-expression which
are actually, in Buddha dharma,
they would call egohood,
which, you're actually--
you think that you're
moving towards
enlightenment, but you're
moving towards-- it's
almost like megamaniacal.
So great question.
AUDIENCE: In the
workspace, I would
notice that a lot of
people are working
from this egomaniacal space.
They're working
for self-interest.
They're working to
try to get ahead.
They're working to try to
make a name for themselves.
How does one who is trying
to work from a deeper
place, trying to
express big self,
do that amongst all
these other influences?
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: Well,
I think that-- one
of the ways of
understanding this
is that I think that,
again, none of us
go through our
childhood unscathed.
None of us come into
the world unscathed.
We have the imprints of
our maternal lineage,
our paternal lineage.
And I also think that when
consciousness comes in,
there's other elements that
are probably not even our own.
They're things that are
being passed down to us
that we are here to work on.
And my understanding is,
basically, our core wound, what
hurts us the most--
for me, it was
feeling disconnected-- starts
to become your vocation.
So if you sit with that feeling
of what's not working for you
and be curious about
it, that's what
evolves into what your vocation,
the thing you're offering.
So for example, here, in the
realm of the bodhisattva,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], is
shown with thousands of eyes.
And those eyes are to look out
at the suffering of the world,
to understand the
suffering of the world.
When you're here, the word
is basically, make your world
a seeming paradise
while you feel
the pain of habitual patterns.
This is the place
of sad joy, which
is actually an amazing,
amazing place to be.
The movie "Inside Out" explores
the theme of sadness and joy
together.
It leads for a richer life, even
though typically, we're like,
I want more joy, don't
want more sadness.
I just read last
night an article
on the geography of sorrow.
This person asked this African
woman, why are you so joyous?
She said, because I cry so much.
I cry so much.
Our joy is accelerated
and amplified
by the more that we can go
in our sorrow, our hurt, all
those things.
And in the workplace,
that's the conversation
we're going to
start to get into.
We don't want to say,
here's my work persona.
We want to bring all of you.
We're better off that way.
And how we manage
that, well, we're
all still figuring
that out right now,
how we can be fully
human everywhere.
VAN RIPER: Thank you, Austin.
AUSTIN HILL SHAW: Thank you.